hey there friends so check this out
you've probably seen me doing this on
occasion in my performance videos and
it's kind of similar to something else
that I've done like this what do they
have in common it is a dance step called
a chaet and I'm going to show you the
basics of how to do that in this
video
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we're going to be working real
hard on those bodies and specifically
one of my favorite dance steps but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrro Tera light toys spin balls
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission now the
version of shaes that I'm doing here are
not precisely what you might be taught
in a ballet or modern dance class the
theory there is just that you're
literally chaining together steps as you
go across the stage it's a similar idea
but I'm taking a wider stance in doing
it and I'm putting less emphasis on
making the motion of my body go up as
I'm taking these steps all that said it
still creates what I think is a really
really cool silhouette on stage
especially when put together with a
bunch of Po moves that do similar things
all right so first things first we're
going to learn how to just turn our body
full 180° because sometimes I find that
even that is a little bit of a challenge
so what you're going to do is you're
going to find yourself a spot to stand
in over on stage right and you're going
to go ahead and pick up your whole body
and you're going to Pivot off of your
lead foot I am heading over towards
stage left so that means that I'm going
to be pivoting off of the ball of my
left foot and Swinging my right foot
around boom to face my entire body up
stage now I'm going to do the same thing
again but I'm going to step forward with
my left foot instead of my right foot
this time so I'm going to be pivoting
off of the right foot taking my whole
body up and swinging my left leg around
to face me back down stage again going
to pick up the right
foot swivel around to go face upstage
pick up the left foot and swivel around
to face down stage now I'm going to take
my uh take the same lead back across
bringing my left foot around and then my
right foot around my left foot around
and then my right foot around I'm kind
of thinking of this basically as almost
being like basketball pivots in some
ways if you remember playing basketball
and having to do those pivots as you go
back and forth uh it feels really
similar to that now the other part of
this in addition to being able to take a
step forward is that we also need to be
able to take a step backwards so now
when I pick up my weight rather than
swinging my right foot around forwards
toward stage left I'm going to swing it
around back behind me but I'm still
going to wind up facing upstage now I'm
going to do the same thing picking up my
whole body and pivoting off of the ball
of my right foot boom to wind up facing
down stage again pick up my right foot
pivot off my left so that I'm facing
upstage and pick up my left foot pivot
off my right so that I'm facing down
stage going to head back across picking
myself up and Swinging my left foot
around behind me picking up swinging my
right foot around behind me picking up
swinging my left foot around behind me
picking up swinging my right foot around
behind me so the first exercise is just
taking steps forward where we turn our
whole body
180° the second exercise is taking steps
backwards turning our whole body 180° in
the process at which point the next step
in this process pun intended is to chain
the two things together hence the word
sha it means chain in French so I'm
going to swing my right foot around
and now instead of swinging my left foot
in front I'm going to swing it behind me
now I did the same thing where I wind up
going from facing up stage to facing
down stage but you'll note that every
time I took a step I was turning my
whole body to my left again I pick up
and swing my right foot in front I pick
up and swing my left foot behind and I
wind up turning my whole body to the
left if I go back to Stage right here
I'm going to pick up my left foot
stepping forward my right foot stepping
back left foot stepping forward right
foot stepping back now when you get a
good feel for this boom boom boom boom
you're just going to be able to take
those steps from one side of the stage
to another uh notice I am spotting where
I am going this entire way through that
is going to help you both keep from
getting too dizzy as well as make sure
that you stay more or less moving in a
straight line if you're finding this
movement difficult one of the ways that
you can practice it is actually just by
lying on the floor and initiating
movement with your feet or hips and just
kind of letting your body sink in behind
it start by crossing your right foot
over your left and let your entire body
just seem to follow it along as though
it's just a sack of potatoes being
dropped into a slot that the right foot
is opened up likewise you can cross over
and reach behind with your left foot and
let it Le your entire body over until
you wind up line down face up once again
you can then go back to the the other
way reaching your left foot across your
right and letting your whole body fall
into that position facing straight down
against the ground and then pointing
your right foot back behind you and
letting your whole body just fall back
into that position where you're staring
up at the ceiling okay so now we're
going to get the POI involved in all of
this and we're going to kind of build up
to doing full chenes with the POI just
like we did with our footwork here's how
you're going to start over on stage
right and you're going to spin your poy
in together same I want you to be
spinning the clockwise as you're facing
down stage here and as you reach around
with that right foot you're also going
to let your PO Swing Out away from you
and you're going to swing them back over
so that as you're facing upstage the PO
now appear to be spinning
counterclockwise you're going to step
forward with your left and as you do so
again you're going to swing those po out
towards stage left and then bring them
back around spinning clockwise relative
to you facing down stage again the right
foot steps forward you're going to going
to swing those po out away from you and
then bring them back around spinning
counterclockwise as you look up stage
swing them away from you and wind up
facing down stage with the POI spinning
clockwise we're going to go back across
and this time as the PO go up and over
we're going to pick the left foot up
with them and we wind up facing upstage
with the POI spinning counterclockwise
again as the PO go up we pick up our
right foot and we come around to face
down stage with the poy spinning
clockwise as the PO go up we pick up the
left foot facing up stage going
counterclockwise as the PO go up we pick
up the right foot and we wind up facing
down stage with the PO spinning
clockwise so Al together then we go from
clockwise to
counterclockwise to clockwise to
counterclockwise back to clockwise and
go back spinning
counterclockwise
clockwise
counterclockwise and clockwise here's
what those turns are going to look like
from your perspective notice how we're
always kind of pushing the POI and your
feet out in the same direction as we're
moving over to stage
[Music]
left and now for our steps back we're
going to wait until the POI is pointed
straight out to Stage right and we're
going to kind of sweep both the POI and
our feet back behind us so as we step
back with the right we wind up with the
pois spinning counterclockwise as we
face up stage now we're going to go
ahead and once again when the PO are
pointed straight over to Stage right
we're going to sweep back with our left
foot and wind up facing down stage with
a POI spinning clockwise we sweep back
and around with the right foot to get to
counterclockwise we sweep back and
around with the left foot to wind up
clockwise we go back to Stage right by
waiting until the PO are pointing
straight out to stage left and as they
go up and over we go back with our left
again as they go up and over we go back
with our right as they go up and over we
go back with our left and as they go up
and over we go back with our right so Al
together then it's stepping back with
the right with the left with the right
with the left we take it back around
stepping left and then right and then
left
and then right got it and once again
this is what this looks like from your
perspective as we push back with both
the POI and your feet stepping across
the
[Music]
stage so our pen ultimate step here is
that we're going to chain together a
step forward and a step back so I'm
going to step forward with my right when
the POI are sweeping down past my feet
right there and then I'm going to go
ahead and switch to uh stepping back
with my left foot as my POI are pointing
back over to Stage right boom like so so
once again I sweep with the right foot
around to
counterclockwise and then Sweep with the
left foot around to clockwise I'm going
to take that back the other way so now
when the PO are pointing up I'm going to
pick up my left foot and then as they're
spinning off towards stage left I bring
them back with my right foot I bring
them forward with my left and back with
my right like so so again I'm going
right forward left behind right forward
left behind and then left forward right
behind left forward right behind like so
and if at this point you're feeling a
little Saucy you can try just going
straight through without without
stopping so you can take your shaes all
the way
over to stage left and then all the way
over to Stage right like so how about
that and once again this is what that
looks like from your
[Music]
[Applause]
perspective
so once you've got this down and
together same I actually recommend going
through all of the same steps with all
the different timing and Direction modes
that way you can be sure that you know
exactly how to make these turns happen
regardless of how the PO is spinning
when you happen to be using these steps
when all the pieces come together you
wind up being able to do some really
beautiful moves across the stage and
hopefully being able to keep track of
how those moves work along the way and
thus far I've only showed you this
traveling back and forth across the
stage from stage left to Stage right but
there's no reason that we have to do it
that way we could instead take our shaes
and walk around in a circle with them
this kind of takes us into similar
territory to what Nick woy used to do
with his whirling dervish work
essentially we're just taking that same
idea of the chaet and turning it into a
little bit of a circle by stepping not
quite straight out to the side but just
short of it as we go around in a circle
so let me show you what these shes look
like in all the different timing and
Direction modes as well as taking them
around in a big
[Music]
circle
awesome so I hope this is helpful please
show me your videos of yourself using
shaes in your flow post video online and
make sure to tag me I am drexfactor on
Instagram Tik Tok and YouTube please
make sure to like comment share and
subscribe to help other people find this
video and to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now if you like these
videos where I'm teaching po moves and
po dance and you want to see more of
them there is a great way that you can
help me out in making that happen and
that is by signing up to support them
over on patreon you can do that at
patreon.com drexfactor poy you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
po spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if you're looking for
more po dance action I highly recommend
this video on Advanced reels that will
help you be able to move around freely
in space with your py Trix so do give
that a look thanks so much for watching
make sure to go out and flow yourselves
and uh I will see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace